[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah bonjour vous voilà enfin vous tombez
bien aujourd'hui grand concours du
meilleur cadeau de l'île aux enfants
vous savez ce que c'est qu'un camelots
et bien camelot c'est un marchand qui
vendre les rues ou dans les foires comme
aujourd'hui des objets de plus de valeur
et sa spécialité c'est le parlaient
beaucoup pour attirer les passants
et à la fin du concours la personne qui
aura vendu le plus d'articles sera
déclaré vainqueur
eh bien ma chère amie à vous eh bien
monsieur 19 je préférerais que vous
commenciez parce que j'étudierais votre
technique comme vous voulez chers amis
noble assistance bon enfant de danton
approchez approchez tous deux souhaitent
venez vite venez vite les autres vous
proposeront des sucreries des petits
objets sans importance et bien tout cela
est trop triste est-ce que moi fut met
en scène dix nomme vous propose autre
chose car il ya donc ces enveloppes mes
pensées secrètes mes rêves les plus fous
oui donc ces enveloppes et grâce à ses
envols entre vous allez pouvoir briller
en société illuminer vos conversations
et vos jeux scintiller de mille peu un
vrai feu d'artifice de mots et pour 1
franc seulement oui affrontements et
aujourd'hui en prime mon chapeau makan
ma chaîne de montres ma montre mes
chaussures à lézard jaune d'australie
enfin au choix tous coudray avec cette
petite enveloppe acquis renard 1 2 un
seul a bon tiens je te serves as bon
mais c'est à vous chers amis
vous avez rendu le goût pour les belles
choses se perd de plus en plus chers
amis
dis-moi françois je préférerais que ce
soit toi qui prennent mon tout parce que
je ne me sens pas tout à fait prête à
bondir
comme du voudra julie en piste les
enfants les enfants venaient c'est par
ici que ça va se passer
attention départ mais la main' moselle
messieurs c'est ici ici naeem en cet
endroit précis que va se dérouler avant
la plus exceptionnelle de la journée la
plus merveilleuse ventes de l'année j'ai
les plus beaux spas long du monde j'en
ai des bleus j'en ai des verts jaunes et
des rouges j'en ai des mauves tenait un
petit pois je me sente 10 pour genève
carouge année 140 chalets à rayures
journée se croyait les plus beaux
ballons du maintien j'en ai même des
creusé avec un petit peu de colle pour
les réparer pour les bricoleurs les dix
ballons les dix ballons non pas 3 francs
n'ont pas de francs 1 franc un misérable
petit 1 franc les divas l'eau attention
c'est une offre unique que françois
lemarchand de ballons de l'île aux
enfants c'est bien moi vous connaissez à
l'honneur en sept minutes top chrono est
de vous offrir attention les débats loin
tranquille et balmain qui est malin
voilà je vous sers à droite je vous sers
gauche je vous sers je ne vous sert plus
de deux clients parfois c'est pas
terrible en fait mon frère françois tu
es déçu un peu ne vous plaignez pas
chers amis vous vous avez peut-être
gagner vous avez un espoir est ce que
moi maintenant je n'ai plus d'espoir je
n'ai rien d'avoir peur de ces frais même
si ce n'est pour l'instant mais c'est
moi le meilleur cadeau de limiter aux
enfants julie maintenant casimir n'étant
toujours pas arrivé bien d'une le plus
tôt dérobés c'est à toi aller avec
d'accord j'ai un peu le trac bon marché
alors approché crochet je ne mangerai
pas
il avait toutes sortes comme les étoiles
dans le ciel des cerises du citron
départ avec vous du caramel dur des
bombes au poivre pour les casimir us un
fond laissant dame qui dit mieux et puis
tenez vous m sympathique je rajoute sans
grade 1 franc les 200 roms vers la
maison ne recule devant aucun sacrifice
je rajoute encore soldes 300 grammes
pour un fonds qui on veut ne vous
bousculez retournera voilà voilà voilà
je suis en tête
voilà casimir qui arrive casimir mon
vieux dépêche toi tu es sans retard
katif pour les hommes de toute façon ça
n'a aucune importance et pourquoi parce
que de toute façon c'est moi qui vais
gagner le concours tu es vraiment trop
sûr de toi qu'il compte quasi mais vas
faire ton boniments on verra après ce
que le plus vous allez voir vous allez
voir les enfants
approchez vous allez voir casimir le roi
du baratin leur roi des camelots et je
vous propose aujourd'hui je ne vais pas
attendre plus longtemps voici ce que je
vous propose des chefs-d'oeuvre des
chefs-d'oeuvre peint par le plus grand
des génie de la peinture moderne votre
serviteur chacun de ces tableaux en
couleur représente un super gloubiboulga
et ceci je vous le signale au passage
pour le prix modique d'offres seulement
1 francs seulement et en prime chaque
acheteur pourra passer un après midi
avec moi dans l'île aux enfants alors
qu'ils ont vaincu en vo qui en veulent
voilà je l'avais bien dit hein ne vous
battez pas il y en aura pour tout le
monde
apprenez les magnifiques patty schnyder
voilà voilà qui n'est pas servie qui
n'est pas servie voilà voilà on a six
étoiles et voilà
alors
ça y est vous en avez tous bien
[Applaudissements]
casimir garde il ils ont jeté toutes tes
tableaux je voulais comprendre de telles
horreurs
alors je ne comprends rien ils sont
beaux jeunes j'ai passé presque une
heure pour les peindre tôt ce qu'ils
ignorent c'est pas grave dit on fera
d'autres encore plus beau et la
prochaine fois et puis tu sais tu n'as
aucune raison d'être triste casimir mais
pourquoi si toi
[Musique]